[Musique]
l'ordre du jour pour ces jeunes
conseillers départementaux c'est le
bilan des actions de l'année 2017 2018
ces collégiens de 5ème 4ème et de 3ème
venus de toute l'île et réunit
aujourd'hui représentent les 233
conseillers départementaux de la règne à
leur montrer tout ce qu'on a vécu tout
pendant toute une année de mandature
c'est vrai que c'est très intéressant
parce que on a fait quand même au moins
huit attrait action ça leur permet de
prendre conscience de
de beaucoup d'actions qui ont été mises
en place le conseil départemental des
jeunes à axer les actions de cette année
sur deux grandes thématiques la sécurité
routière et le harcèlement
il a également poursuivi ses actions de
proximité comme les rencontres dans les
ehpad et le concours de slam
donc pour ma part les actions qui m'ont
le plus marqué et les actions les plus
grandes ça a été la sécurité routière ce
qu'on a fait intervenir des médecins
pédopsychiatres par un médecin
pédopsychiatre la gendarmerie nationale
la vice-présidente de l'éducation et le
président du conseil départemental est
venu donc pour vous dire que c'était une
action très importante et très
médiatisée je pense qu'on a beaucoup
appris et ensuite il ya eu une action de
sensibilisation contre le harcèlement
chances que ça aussi ça a été une des
grosses actions qu'on a fait est une des
actions les plus importantes les
élections du nouveau bureau du conseil
départemental des jeunes auront lieu en
novembre prochain
[Musique]